now thanks to the Washington examiner we
know who some of these folks are
Congressman Gallagher was just so great
on the show last night we got huge
reaction and among the names lobbying on
behalf of tick tock which is owned by
the CCP controlled bite dance are the
following former Republican Senate
Majority Leader Trent Lott powerful
former Democratic senator John Bro of
Louisiana former Republican Congressman
Jeffrey Dunham and former Democratic
Congressman Barton Gordon also former
high-profile staffers are getting into
the game including former Pelosi senior
advisor Michael bloom and former Kevin
McCarthy political advisor Freddie
Barnes
all were asked to appear with us tonight
with the exception of Bloom who couldn't
make the timing work they refused
joining us now is Senator Tom Cotton who
has long warned about Tick-Tock Senator
that's quite a list and that's just
scratching the surface
what does that tell you about the
revolving door of power to influence
peddling in Washington especially on
behalf essentially of the CCP
well Laura it was a great interview you
had with my friend Mike Gallagher last
night he's right tick tock is like a
kind of digital fentanyl or trojan horse
on the phones of America's youth if you
have it on your phone you should delete
it and probably get a new phone as well
and these former members of Congress and
Congressional AIDS should know better
than lobbying for a company that is
directed by at the behest of the Chinese
Communist party that is part of its
massive surveillance Network that is
going to give access to hundreds of
millions of Americans phones going for
today and going forward if it's not
removed from those phones if it's not
banned nationally in this country Mike
Gallagher and I also have legislation
that would close this loophole he spoke
about that would require any person
who's lobbying for one of these Chinese
companies to register not just as a
lobbyist and require diligent
journalists at places like Washington
examiner to go ferret them out but
rather register as a foreign agent
because in China there simply is no line
between the Communist Party and Chinese
companies yeah I mean that seems like
such a no-brainer at this point Senator
so I'm so glad you're pursuing this but
today at the New York Times deal book
Summit the CEO of tick tock address
criticism that they are just controlled
by the Chinese government watch this
we take all these concerns very
seriously for us you know no U.S no
foreign government has asked us for U.S
user Data before really to heaven and if
they did we would say no
Senator I'm sorry does that even pass
the straight face test
no and if you said no we might go the
way of Jack Ma and be disappeared and
never heard from again either look Tick
Tock is under the thumb of Chinese
Communists it has to answer to the
Chinese Communist party it has to do
what the government says it can access
all the data on your phone to include
all the other apps and your content and
your text messages your emails your
browser history it can even remotely
control your camera and your microphone
you should delete tick tock from your
phone and probably get a new phone if
you have it on there now and that's to
say nothing of the kind of content that
the Chinese Communist Party allows on
Tick Tock in their country which is
basically respect your elders and do
your homework and eat your vegetables
and what you find on it here in America
I'm not sure they're even getting
vegetables Senator but uh it's good to
see you tonight thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else